hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the gold money asian rapid tournament
it's vladislav artemia versus levon
arunyan and
this is the second game of their match
well the position on the board is
actually from the first game i just want
to show you the position from the first
game and what happened in the first game
and then we're gonna quickly shift to
the second game
uh so this was the position levon really
pushed some pawns here
uh tried to you know make it really
uncomfortable for black on the king's
side but
then uh when this position was reached
uh he had to decide on how to continue
and he decided for this knight to b5
move he attacked the queen
and now the queen can't retreat just
anywhere because the queen has to keep
an eye on the c6 pawn
so here queen to b7 was played by
artemis
knight attacks the queen once again
queen c7 and now 11 played knight back
to b5 so here
uh the position repeated a few times and
it was in this position that they agreed
to a draw
so lavon was not able to push for more
than uh a draw with the white pieces
and now we have the second game where
artemia has the white pieces and
this game it's just uh well it has
everything so without further ado let's
check it out
uh as uh well uh it has a few positive
video moments you're gonna enjoy all of
them uh so let's check it out
artemis opens with the red opening
knight to f3
we have d5 uh g3 g6 and now
c4 they are challenging this central
pawn uh we have d
captures on c4 and not knight to a3
going after the pawn this way
we have bishop to g7 by levon knight
captures on c4 and
now c5 we have bishop to g2 preparing
the castle just nicely developing knight
to c6 and now d3 uh and here levon
played bishop to d7
which is uh well which is a bit tricky
as it allows
uh white to go for a very very
interesting idea there is one game in
the database where uh just castles was
played but here
uh artemiev says uh your c5 pawn is
undefended i'm gonna play bishop to e3
even though it
kind of prevents my pawn from being
developed but you have to react to this
and uh it is now as of move 8 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how levon deals with this he starts by
playing b6 he defends the spawn
and you don't have to worry there is no
way of really taking advantage of this
or
a huge diagonal because uh even if you
try something like knight f to e5 and
try to pose some problems for black
black and just capture this it's it's
not a problem
you're going to pick up the rook and now
the problem is after queen captures your
rook is hanging here
so you're going to have the castle and
then we have some like knight captures
and c4d
captures and we have a bishop and the
knight for
bishop in the night for white rook so of
course black is much much better here
so instead after b6 we have d4 uh
striking in the center
and now c captures on the four knight
captures on d4 and
rook the c8 and here the position is
actually really really interesting
and uh well there's one particular move
artemia can play here that really makes
life miserable for black
and he spent over five minutes in the
position for this move which is crazy
because this is rapid chess
players get 15 minutes per game uh so
spending more than five minutes it's
just awesome so feel free to pause the
video here
and try to find this incredible move uh
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations so you must be
at least 2700 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
knight to b5 and this is this is the
good stuff
and now the problem for black is is that
black does not have a good move
if we just continue normal development
let's say knight to f6
then uh black loses on the spot because
we have knight
beat the uh d6 with check attacking both
the rook and the king
so black will capture we're going to
capture with the other knight as well
again forking the
rook and the king king to f8 and now
knight captures and c8 and
once the queen captures it it doesn't
seem like quite got all that much from
the position but now rook the c1
and now you can see that this knight is
attacked twice and also we're
threatening queen to d6 check to attack
at the third time
so king has to go back king to e8 and
now we're still gonna play queen to d6
there's a triple attack on the knight
now and now once black for example
unpins we're just gonna capture here
with the rook
and then we're gonna see queen captures
rook captures and we're gonna have this
position where white is up material he's
upon and he's up the exchange he has a
rook for a knight
uh so it's just uh well uh completely
winning position for white
so really really awesome stuff so after
this night the b5 move you couldn't
really just continue developing you have
to play some like king to f8 and then
your position is just i mean
uh terrible and uh well uh this is
probably
why uh after spending more than five
minutes artemia did not play this he
said all right but what if he just plays
king to f8 yes his position is bad
but i've already spent more than five
minutes uh maybe maybe i don't want to
go for this so instead
after levon's rook to c8 artemy just
castled so he didn't go for this killer
knight to b5 move and now
uh we have knight captures on d4 by
levon and this is again a crucial move
again if you continue development uh
you're just getting crushed just knight
captures on c6
bishop captures bishop captures with
check now rook captures and here we just
trade queens captures captures in 95 and
white wins
uh the rook is under attack if you move
the rook then uh well whatever knight
captures on f7 delivers check and picks
up the other rook on h8
so levon of course spots this he plays
knight captures on d4 we have bishop
characters and now
knight to f6 he's very happy to finally
develop this knight and castle the
safety
we have knight to e5 and excellent
square for artemis knight and now
uh levon castles we rook to c1 and levon
doesn't
think twice he just trades here doesn't
really waste any time queen captures
and now plays bishop to b5 developing
this bishop with tempo is definitely the
way to go
uh and here uh the situation on the
clock is eight minutes for artemyev and
13 minutes for lebron and artemyev again
goes into a deep thing
and again spends a couple of minutes and
now he tries to sacrifice this pawn he
plays rook to d1 he says
okay you can capture this pawn and then
i'm gonna have maybe a nice discovery on
your queen and although it doesn't seem
like there's a good discovery
uh levon doesn't even care about the
pawn he just plays queen to c8 but
i'm going to show you what happens if
you capture the pawn uh levon probably
had something like knight to c6 in mind
attacking the queen in the e7 pawn
and now you are threatening some bishop
captures maybe with a discovery on the
queen but the queen
has to move so it doesn't really matter
but you can play queen d6 still keep an
eye on the pawn and there are no good
discoveries you're going to play rogue
d2 attack the bishop here
but just queen to e6 and now you
sidestep from the d file attack your
bishop and that's
all there is queen e1 with a double
attack on the bishop we can just uh
offer a queen trade and once this
finally happens white will win back his
pawn and that's it we get this position
which is
isn't really all that much so uh while
uh
rook the d1 is very very nice levon
doesn't want to waste time he just plays
queen to c8 and now offers a queen trade
uh artemiev goes e3 he says okay we can
trade but
i'm gonna be the one that has a rook on
the and the open c
file and uh artemiev is down to three
minutes already whereas levon
has some 12 and something minutes on the
clock we have rook to d8 levon just
continues development and now
b3 artemia doesn't want to spend any
more time he just plays some useful
moves here
and then now we have queen to b8 and
this is the the
second well maybe not the greatest move
by the one because now
white retains uh well really really an
active queen and the black's queen
here isn't really doing all that much i
will just show a fun line
because it really just equalizes the the
position is already equal but it's very
complicated but you can equalize easily
with knight to g4
seems like a really stupid move because
white can just eliminate the defender of
the knight and then grab the knight but
you have to look one move further and
then you see it
because after queen captures and rook
captures yes you win the knight but now
this bishop says hello everyone and he
goes bishop to e2 now
with a double attack attacking the rook
and the knight and once you move the
rook you're going to win your piece back
and now we've basically traded off
everything if anyone's better here it
could only be black because
well the material is equal completely
equal but black already has a nice rook
on the open c file so
yeah maybe maybe it's a little
advantageous for black
but okay after b3 levon played queen to
b8 and this really
allows uh artemiev to go for some uh
epic moves he plays queen to a1
we reach the position from the thumbnail
now and you can see there's a lot of
stuff here on on this diagonal
but if these knights move uh then well
uh
black could lose some material and here
one should play some like knight to e8
uh just a nice safe square for the night
and
exposed this diagonal to his own bishop
so if this knight ever moves
you can start trading pieces however uh
levon played knight to d7
which kind of makes sense uh there's now
a triple attack on the knight here
and he says all right now we trade
everything and uh you know it's a great
position for me
but not so quickly because here pause
the video for the second time and try to
find a really really impressive move for
artemis while i give you a couple of
seconds
uh think of of tal's hippopotamus move
and then you will you will see it
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
letting the hippo drown and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight captures on f7 and this is just
deadly
uh problem is if you just capture the
the knight and bishop captures on g7
a white one upon white white's position
is incredible once this bishop comes
here for example that's
it for the for the black king uh so
levon had to go for the other line which
is
far worse but you have to you have to
spot it the bishop captures on d4
and now artemis just plays queen
captures on d4
uh because he's thinking queen captures
on d4 king captures knight
then i'm gonna deliver check with my
queen and pick up the bishop on b5 make
sense because you know
why not but there is a greater move and
this game
it's like this game whenever a movie is
played it features a much greater move
but knight h6 is just crushing
uh it seems like it's not much problem
is after king g7 and we
win back the bishop here queen captures
uh the the king has to go back and then
you really don't have all that much to
to do and if you capture the knight then
there's queen to h4 check king g7
queen captures an e7 check king g8 and
now bishop to h3 going here for bishop
to e6
and now there's really not all that much
but also uh the knight here uh
can just be captured if if you ever want
to so if something like queen to c7 we
defended
now we can just play a4 uh move the
bishop back and then go for this
beautiful bishop to e6 check king to h8
now we capture here and black is getting
checkmated so captures captures and
now of course uh sorry uh queen captures
and now of course
just queen queen to f6 check queen to g7
we're gonna pick up the rook with check
queen has to block and this is now
checkmate
so this is only one of the lines but
it's one of the nicer ones so i decided
to show you
so not capturing with the automatic
recapture knight to h6
brilliant but okay uh our team we have
captured on d4
we have king captures on f7 and now
queen d5 check you're gonna win back
your piece and
you know keep an extra pawn and in the
better game so this is also very
impressive
artemis is very low on time we have to
remember that queen king the g7
queen captures on b5 and now knight to
f6
uh offering a rook trade uh artemia
happily obliges we have captures
captures and now bishop to f3
controlling this knight so it's a great
square for the bishop also you free the
g2 square for the king
and now you just have to figure out how
to exploit black's weakness
black has three pawn islands you have
two black is down a pawn
so uh definitely you you can do
something here we have
a5 here uh expanding on the queen side a
little bit now queen to e5 and artemis
queen is now a monster here
we have king to f8 unpinning and now g4
preparing g5 and then something like
queen to h8 so it could be it could be
really crazy
so h6 stopping g5 but only for the
moment because
h4 now g5 is coming yet again and here
you don't really have a good move for
black so uh the only thing left for
levon is queen to d6 he has to trade
down into an end game
uh but it's a much better end game for
white so queen character spawn captures
and now king the g2 you could also argue
maybe going
after the queen side pawns is better
artemis has a different plan king the g2
we have g5 by levon and now king to g3
we have king to g7 and now
bishop to c6 again controlling all the
squares that the knight can use to jump
to so the knight for the moment can't
really do anything
we have d5 now with the idea of using
the e4 square to
deliver check to the white king then
maybe go to c3 harass the queen side
pawns
so f3 preventing this and now king to f7
so
level really really fighting back here
from from a worse position
artemis trades here once captures
captures and now executes f4 and now
here
artemyev is getting a pass pawn at some
point uh but maybe
f4 was a bit too soon maybe the f3 pawn
is really
needed here because the knight doesn't
really have any square on the board
and of course you can't trade pieces
because white is up a pawn that's of
course completely winning
so here maybe you should just uh you
know maybe re-maneuver your bishop for
example to d3
uh to kind of take away all of the
squares from the black king as well and
then maybe try and try and push your
pawn or maybe just improve the position
of your
over your king a little bit still uh but
he played f4
and now levon immediately jumps in with
the knight knight e4 checking f3
knight to c3 now going after the a2 pawn
and still the position is fine for white
but damien has to play a4 but
he doesn't uh a a4 and then you just
wait for
uh you know black to make a move and
then you slowly but surely improve your
position
you can even do this maneuver again keep
uh take away the
g6 square from uh the black king then
you can capture and then it's going to
be perfectly fine for white
however here after knight to c3f
captures and g5 was played right away
and this kind of makes it easier for
levon
a little bit king g6 now comes king to
f4
and now knight captures an a2 we have
bishop captures on d5
now comes b5 and here bishop to e4 check
so we get a similar position
but not as strong as the knight already
captured the pawn on a2 so king g7
king e5 and now a4 it's lavon who
created a passport as well
captures captures and now you have to be
careful so
king the d4 this is the only winning
move for artemia you have to bring the
king
uh inside the square of the pawn so here
we have a3
and now again the crucial move i'm not
going to ask you to pause the video but
you probably know what you have to do
and so does dartmouth but he's
extremely low on time or seconds on the
clock uh and he makes uh
well uh the the wrong step with the king
here
he plays king to c4 but uh when the
when the only winning idea was king to
d3 and this is
uh this is a move that you can't know
because
they're they don't say for nothing in
chess when they're when you have a
knight you have a chance
because the knight is so unpredictable
the bishop is considered to be a
stronger piece but in lower time form
it's
you know the jump is j the knight is
just uh you know
uh completely unpredictable and even for
for a player like
artemiev uh you know you simply can't do
it point is after king to c4 uh levon
just played knight to c2 and he took
away the b3 square and now the king
cannot approach the pass pawn
so here you would have to go king to c3
now knights to e to check and after king
to b3
uh a2 was played and now of course if
the
pawn is captured then knight the c3
check picks up the bishop but
let's go back a few moves uh just to
show you uh
in this position why instead of king to
see for king to d3 was better
because then uh there's nothing you can
do if knights the c1 check we play king
to c2 if a2
are trying to give up the knight for the
queen we just play king b2 and now the
position is winning
uh there's uh no good square for the
knight you don't have a check the d3
square is covered by the bishop
and after knight to e2 uh you don't have
to worry about anything you're going to
play bishop to f5 and still your your
position is just amazing the pawn and
bishop
control all of the squares so the white
king cannot approach these spawns
this is nicely protected and there's
nothing for for for
black to do you can never attack the
bishop because then we
improve our pawn structure the d4 square
is covered by knight so you have all the
time in the world to capture the pawn
and then advance the king all the way
back
but in the game king the c4 was played
now comes knight to c1 and now the b3
square has been uh
taken away from the uh white king we
have king to c3 but now
knight to e to check king b3 uh sorry
king b3 and now a2 and now like we said
you can't capture because knight c3
check wins the bishop
so instead we have king to b2 but now
comes knight to c3
again you can't capture because of
queening so the bishop has to move we
have bishop to c2 and now
knight to d5 going after the e3 pawn and
then you have doubled pawns on the g
file that's not a problem
so e4 was played now comes knight e3
again you can't capture because the
bishop hangs
bishop to d3 now knight captures and g4
the knight is just a
nightmare here we have bishop to e2
attacking the knight
knight f2 now attacking this pawn we
have e5 knight h3 now attacking this
pawn you can't
defend it it's on a dark square king
captures an a2 now comes knight captures
on g5 and of course there is no possible
way of winning this king b3 was played
knight f7 attacks the pawn e6 we have
knight g5 attacking the pawn
bishop to g for defending now king f6
and the knight
and the pawn will now fall king c4 uh we
have knight captures on e6 bishop
captures on e6
and he was in this position on move 58
that the game ended in a draw
due to insufficient material so really
incredible game artemiev
had so many chances but he uh you could
see that he
the line was prepared but those
positions where you had to solve them
they were not prepared so he spent a lot
of time
trying to figure them out he found that
beautiful the you know drowning hippo
move with knight captures on f7
but he missed some crucial continuations
and that will simply not do if you want
to beat levon arena in the finals of
this very nice tournament
so game two also ends in a draw and
we'll see what happens next
this was amazing i i enjoyed it
immensely and hope you guys did as well
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank tom
daral
added the t there uh lens hassan connor
clark james walker and peter milner for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this uh you
know amazing tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day